[Musica]
buongiorno a tutti sono felici di essere
qua di parlarmi del mio sport della
plath però prima che prima di fare
riferimenti diretti alla mia carriera
come io ho iniziato a fare
ne vorrei parlare di di un grande
personaggio dell'apnea che risponde al
nome di enzo maiorca un nome storico che
negli anni sessanta uso a sfidare la
scienza andando quello contro quello che
il più grande fisiologo dell'equipe
gusto sosteneva potesse essere un limite
per l'uomo il muro dei 50 metri
enzo maiorca per primo su però questa
barriera per primo osò andare oltre
questi 50 metri mettendo in dubbio
quello che il professor gabarrou
fisiologo delle che questo era convinto
potesse dire limitare l'uomo
provocandone la morte
e io ho incontrato mayorga per tante
volte abbiamo avuto incontri insieme e
maiorca è sceso anche oltre i 100 metri
per ogni volta che lo ritrovavo dicevo
dai raccontami quel tuffo a 50 metri
perché aveva qualcosa di magico rispetto
agli altri record dei numerosi record
della sua carriera e ogni volta lì così
nel raccontarmi quell'avventura diceva
io non potevo accettare che questi
medici mi chiudessero all'interno di
questa gabbia limitandomi nelle mie
potenzialità
nessuno di loro era sceso a quelle quote
nessuno di loro sapeva quello che il mio
corpo provava vicino a quelle di meno a
quelle distanze a quelle profondità
sentivo di poter andare oltre e quindi
così inizia ad allenarmi andando contro
quello che la medicina riteneva potesse
essere veramente un limite per l'uomo
il professore baru aveva costruito un
contenitore che aveva più o meno le
caratteristiche di un uomo con una
capacità vitale di 6 litri se litro e
mezzo e vede che questo contenitore ogni
volta che mi ha calato oltre 50 metri
una volta salvato era imploso
schiacciato una legge fisica dice che in
un gas a temperatura costante pressione
volume sono inversamente proporzionali
quando noi scendiamo sott'acqua ogni
dieci metri la pressione aumenta di un
atmosfera quindi tutti i volumi che ci
portiamo dietro si riducono in modo
proporzionale
il volume più importante quello
polmonare
a 60 50 metri abbiamo se atmosfere
abbiamo un volume polmonare che è un
sesto rispetto a quello iniziale e
secondo baru quello poteva essere la
causa dell'implosione quindi di
conseguenza alla morte per l'uomo che
arrivava a 50 metri quindi immaginatevi
enzo maiorca in acqua pronto a partire
pronto effettuare la capovolta
sapevo che tutta la medicina al mondo
diceva attuativi da sotto e muore questo
bisogno di capire la grandezza di questo
uomo
l'ultima volta che l'ho incontrato ero
con un amico paracadutista e ogni volta
ancora una volta di coda racconta quel
tuffo a 50 metri e allora dico al mio
amico ascolto bene quello che sta
dicendo perché è come se tu fossi lì sul
portellone del tuo aereo pronto a
lanciarti e tutti gli ingegneri
aeronautici al mondo dicono il
paracadute che sulla schiena nell'aria e
non saprà mai questo per farvi capire la
grandezza di questo uomo perché questi
sono lui e il lacma york sono le
leggende dell'apnea e perché anche se un
giorno arriveremo a 300 metri nella
leggenda della pena e resteranno loro
perché noi scendiamo sott'acqua e a
certe quote non ci siamo implosi non sia
schiacciati e non siamo morti perché la
nostra nel nostro corpo non è un
semplice contenitore reagisce in modo
diverso rispetto ad un semplice
contenitore abbiamo passato i primi nove
mesi della nostra vita in un elemento
acquatico e quindi con l'app nè a noi
riusciamo a risvegliare riprendere
queste situazioni ancestrale che ci
hanno accompagnato in questa primissima
fase il nostro corpo così come avviene
per i mammiferi marini le balene le
foche e delfini si adatta a quelle quote
con delle situazioni fisiologiche che ti
permettono di arrivare idee di
sopravvivere i un effetto chiamato black
sheep richiamo di sangue tipico di chi
mammiferi che è stato scoperto che
nell'uomo scendendo sott'acqua il nostro
volume vero si riduce il suo volume
polmonare però lì non resta il vuoto il
sangue viene preso dalle gambe e delle
braccia dove non abbiamo organi
fondamentali di sopravvivenza viene
spinto all'interno di questo spazio
lasciato vuoto il sangue un liquido il
liquido incomprimibile e per questo
motivo non ci schiacciamo
maiorca ritorno in superficie con questo
cartellino ma qualche giorno prima di
effettuare questo tuffo a 50 metri via
barro scese in sicilia siracusa per
cercare di fargli cambiare idea e si
incontrarono in ogni volta che racconta
questa storia io vengo affascinato dalle
sue parole dalla sua tenacia e dice
gabarrou qui iniziano a parlare
l'intento è l'obiettivo di gaber lo era
quello di fargli cambiare idea
due giorni prima si incontrano parlano
tra di loro in inglese alla fine di
questa chiacchierata anch'esso kabalu
dice enzo maiorca quello che vuoi
tentare tra due giorni è impossibile
maiorca gli stringe la mano e gli dice
impossible diesel opinio lo vedremo tra
due giorni
immaginatevi torna da 50 metri col
cartellino
tutti i lavori scientifici basati sul
teorema fondamentale
l'oms e cras l'uomo si schiaccia non
erano più validi era stato dimostrato il
contrario però dice robero no aspetta un
attimo col continente non andava bene lo
trattiamo un attimo 70 metri impossibile
jacques mayol 75 aspetta un attimo la
facciamo più grosso cento impossibile
enzo maiorca 101 e jacques mayol 105
l'atteggiamento della medicina è
completamente cambiato maiorca entrando
per la prima volta in questo gioiello
della tecnologia che abbiamo qua vicino
a parma si chiama y 40 alla piscina più
profonda al mondo una piscina di 42
metri entrando lì dentro di se avessi
avuto questa struttura a disposizione
sarei andato oltre 200 metri perché oggi
anche grazie a questa cosa possiamo
capire meglio quello che succederà sotto
qual è la fisiologia dell'uomo oltre
certe quote ogni mese susseguono
ricercatori scienziati equipe che ci
studiano ci portano sul fondo con
tecnologie particolari oggi sappiamo
molto molto di più di quello che avviene
nel nostro corpo oltre certe quote e
l'atteggiamento della medicina è
completamente cambiato si parla oggi di
300 metri come limite fisiologico umano
per l'uomo che scende in apnea
non so se considero il 300 metri come il
collasso totale del polmone cioè oltre
quelle quote nulla potrà ulteriormente
in stringersi comprimersi
non so ci saremmo veramente o si dicono
diciamo 300 metri così almeno nei
prossimi tre nei prossimi 50 anni
possiamo scrivere e dire quello che
vogliamo però sicuramente parlare oggi
dei 300 metri è considerato molto meno
da pazzi di quanto non fosse all'epoca
di maiale maiorca il 150 e il 150 kg
toccato nel 1999 io affascinato da
questi due uomini enzo maiorca sciarpa
jol sono arrivato un giorno nella pne a
io ero malato di apnea avevo 8 anni
avevo il mio record di 2 minuti e mezzo
era un montatore quindi nuotavo anche da
piccolo e tutti i giorni un paio d'ore
era in piscina mi annoiavo come tutti i
bambini che fanno nuoto e quindi mi
nascondevo sotto la scaletta cercavo di
resistere il più possibile a scuola un
giorno avevo avevo 8 anni mio record di
2 minuti e mezzo doveva arrivare a tre
minuti mi ricordo non sapevo come
rilassarmi come respirare un giorno
trattengono il fiato e deciso di
stabilire mio record maestra 2 42 45 mi
vede mi corre incontro cerca di farmi
parlare e radu e 53 minuti mettevo
rumori strani a tre minuti respir limite
dello svenimento della sincope dedico
maestra tre minuti questa mi ha cacciato
dalla scuola per tre giorni a casa non
vi dico mio padre è un giorno ritornato
a scuola tre giorni dopo mi dice se non
fai più se non mi fa più spaventare di
nuovo come è successo tre giorni fa ti
farò trovare alla fine dell'anno
scolastico l'indirizzo di enzo maiorca
puntualissima mantenere la promessa
arrivo con questo fogliettino alla fine
dell'anno e presi questo foglio lo misi
in un cassetto e non ebbi il coraggio di
usarlo e ogni volta cercavo di
trattenere un po di più il fiato di
migliorarmi ero veramente malato
smisi di fare nuove quindi volevo
diventare una pista migliore scrisse a
enzo maiorca era l'unico riferimento che
avevano c'era inter non c'erano manuali
pfm sapere assolutamente nulla e mi
ricordo una volta di una conferenza mi
chiesero come iniziale far apnea disse a
presenziare in modo diverso scritto una
lettera enzo maiorca eravamo insieme a
questa conferenza dico però non mi ha
mai risposto
maiorca era bravissimo a dribblare le
domande scomode se non ti ho risposto
perché avevi scritto che ri una playlist
mergenti e gli apneisti scendono non
emergono per quello non aveva risposto
quindi iniziò questa ricerca soprattutto
su me stesso grazie e il salto di
qualità l'ho fatto arrivando all elba
termine l'università mi mancavano
qualche ancora qualche mese era nel
gruppo sportivo dei vigili del fuoco
venni trasferito all'isola d'elba e
l'inizio questo questo percorso verso la
profondità non s'è capito l'accento io
arrivo da busto arsizio che non è mai
stata una repubblica marinara quindi
bravo apneista in piscina ma purtroppo
il mare veramente negato
conosco quest'uomo massimo giudicelli
che sarà quello che avrà credere in me
prima ancora che mi prendessi me stesso
che mi porta molto rapidamente in 45
giorni alle quote che noi avevamo
previsto di raggiungere nei successivi 4
5 mesi e quindi un giorno arrivò il
record era di bp con meno 63 ei
raggiungiamo 58 metri di profondità di
pinera questo cubano imbattuto in tutte
le specialità dell'apnea io arrivavo da
gustarsi se non usavo dire a nessuno che
ero lì per superare questo cubano e
quindi così vedo che queste quote però
si avvicinano il 63 di pt ne erano poco
distanti avevo fatto 58 metri un giorno
decido di andare dal corsaro conoscere
il corsaro all'isola dello il corsaro
era l'allenatore di jacques mayol mi
ricordo arrivo al suo centro sub lo
conosco e lo vedevo conoscevo dalle foto
dai libri di maiale maiorca del di
jacques mayol che io avevo imparato a
memoria
quindi lo conosco gli stringo la mano e
dico salve sono umberto pelizzari sono
portoferraio mi sto allenando vorrei
fare un record lo dice ma che quota
stelle beh sono già 55 55 ce ne saranno
5000 nel mondo vieni quando si è un po
più fondo allora torno con giudicelli
questi cinque metri si recuperano
facilmente arrivo intorno al corso del
corsaro 60 metri fa 60 metri
ce ne saranno 500 vedi quando sembrò più
fondo allora ritorniamo con giudicelli
65 in allenamento record i pip in 63
vado al corsara di corsaro o 65 68
c'è la mia tanti nel mondo vieni domani
che ti voglio vedere in acqua non
credeva a nulla ea nessuno e allora mi
ricordo mi presenta il giorno dopo con
giudicelli con la squadra dei
sommozzatori vigili del fuoco avevo di
fronte a me la squadra di assistenza di
jacques mayol sali su questa barca mi
fece trovare questo plaid che già paiolo
usava per le sue preparazioni prima di
un tuffo la respirazione lo yoga
pranayama mi ricordo quel giorno fece
questo tuffo a 68 metri tutti
contentissimi di parti questa mia
avventura quindi si decise la data per
superare per la prima volta pipin in
modo ufficiale e mi ricordo a porto
azzurro stabili questo mio primo record
nel 90 superando per la prima volta ppi
ma giusto per dirvi come il mio la mia
ricerca di limite iniziò e io trovai
quel giorno ero felice di questa cosa ma
sicuramente così sorpreso c'era la rai a
filmarmi nel mio primo record stabilì il
record passo su un buon passaggio
televisivo
due anni dopo in una gara internazionale
ritrovo questo giornalista della rai
chiacchieriamo e mi dice sai siamo
conosciuti due anni fa in occasione del
tuo primo record sinceramente io ero lì
per non tanto per filmare il tuo record
la rai stava producendo un documentario
di medicina e salute
l'argomento era svenimenti e sincopi non
avevano immagini di sincope m'han detto
vai all elba che qualche immagine di
sincope rapporti a casa c'è questo che
sta tentando di battere di pin
questo per farvi capire come io ho
iniziato e penso che se mi fossi tenuto
a queste indicazioni questi limiti molto
molto forti che mi arrivano dalle
persone che si muovono intorno ma che
giustamente midi come dire avevano
un'idea abbastanza negativa rispetto a
quello che stavo facendo
promette oggi non sarei qui a
raccontarvi della mia vita e della mia
storia
ho continuato ho continuato a scendere e
stato per me soprattutto una ricerca
riuscire a capire fino a dove il tuo
corpo può andare quando tu vai
sott'acqua
ti si stabiliscono delle situazioni per
le quali noi non siamo stati creati noi
dobbiamo vivere in un atmosfera
dobbiamo respirare la sott'acqua si
creano situazioni fisiologiche
assolutamente diverse a 150 metri ai 16
vuol dire che il tuo polmone è grande un
sedicesimo rispetto al volume iniziale
il resto del tuo torace e pieno di
sangue
hai un 16 chili su ogni centimetro
quadrato del tuo corpo
hai un cuore che batte a 10 12 14
battiti al minuto
non hai ossigeno quindi il tuo corpo lo
distribuisce nel modo più lento
possibile sott'acqua non hai luce la
forza gravitazionale ce l'ha e ma è
diversa rispetto a quello per cui siamo
con cui siamo stati siamo abituati a
convivere non ai suoni
quindi tu arrivi sul fondo sei un altro
in un mondo diverso e questo ti porta
ogni volta a capire un po di più come
attraverso l'allenamento l'adattamento
fisiologico e l'adattamento anche
mentale psicologico quelle situazioni
poi tutto questo arrivando la ti
permette di vivere ogni volta una
situazione un po più profonda un po più
delicata un'introspezione via via
crescente sul tuo corpo hai una
percezione del corpo che completamente
diversa quindi la rincorsa verso quello
che viene definito il limite non è tanto
per poter stabilire il metro in più ma
per capire un po di più quello che il
tuo corpo lasciato ti sta dicendo
enzo maiorca sempre lui in un suo libro
dice io non ricordo il primo respiro che
ho fatto quando sono venuto al mondo ma
sicuramente c'è qualcosa di comune tra
il primo respiro che faccio quando esco
da un tuffo fondo è il primo respiro che
ho fatto con sono uscito dal corpo di
mia madre
dopo nove mesi di vita acquatica e
questa è una cosa veramente bella tu
quando sei là sotto non sei un terrestre
se un acquatico qualcosa qualche cosa
qualcuno che ha accettato quelle
situazioni lì e poi ritornando in
superficie senti che progressivamente il
tuo corpo ritorna ad essere quello
normale e questa linea questa della
linea di demarcazione tra una vita
acquatica una vita terrestre è
rappresentata proprio da questa prima
inspirazione che effettui nel momento in
cui la tua testa rompe la superficie
dell'acqua ed iniziò a inspirare ha un
sapore molto molto particolare e da lì
in poi ritornerà ad essere il terrestre
per cui sei stato creato ed è questo
fondamentalmente il motivo per cui ho
fatto recco per tutta la vita
ho toccato quote che la medicina
i miei tempi sostenevano ma si potessero
toccare e anche ora che ho smesso di
fare gare ormai da parecchi anni
continuano ad attacco perché quello che
più mi piace fare quello che più mi
affascina e perché è come dire è una
continua ricerca sul tuo corpo e su
quello che il tuo corpo ti può
permettere di vivere in termini di
sensazioni positive e qui o il segnale
mi dice di bbb ho finito ormai da 23
minuti
io ringrazio tutti ringrazio telex e vi
augura bellissima giornata
grazie a voi
[Applauso]
[Musica]